my purpose is a show
well you said show I normally go on
scissors do you yeah should we try it
again yeah
honest okay fine fine paper scissors all
right
you know go first or second second okay
you gotta give the information I know
all right one
hey I'm Robbie Amell I'm Stephen Amell
we are here promoting code eight and we
are going to interview each other hard
for et about what your first question is
now Stephen what was it like starring in
code eight with me considering I'm
playing the handsome and much much
younger leading man did your old age
make it difficult to remember all your
lines no your performance did wonderful
things you Shepherd a project don't
having hit me with kaileena having been
in that role for so long was a was not
only a relief but a familial point of
pride Robbie I have 6.1 million
Instagram followers 2.4 million Twitter
followers a team choice that they
haven't given me the surfboard for yet
multiple fandom awards and have starred
in 170 episodes not to mention the other
shows of arrow as the titular character
how does it feel to have such a
successful cousin I have a Kids Choice
Award but it's from the Netherlands it
says best to Siri what was it for true
Jack's you know all of your success and
all of the fans that love you are pretty
much the main reason we got to make the
movie that we did so it's awesome too
that's not proper what Steve what's your
favorite thing about working with me and
your least favorite my favorite thing
about you working with you is is how
disciplined you are on set and how
there's basically no chance that the
night before a critical scene you want
to go and grab a beer my least favorite
thing is that you're so disciplined on
set and that before a critical scene
will not go and grab one beer can so you
want to go grab some actually as you do
what's one thing I do on set that drives
you crazy
please answer honestly because I want to
better myself as a co-worker and a
person I mean there was nothing that I
would have told you I'd be like why you
doing then weird thing the only
difficult thing with you was your
schedule and that had nothing to do with
you that was just because because you
were the lead of a TV show
so nothing it was awesome okay yeah I
like to play in clash Royale in between
takes so do I remember when we would
call us to set and we'd be like hold on
yeah finish this so other people
probably had problems with us but not me
tough for those people is it my turn or
your turn your turn three
what's the one thing that surprised you
most during our process of creating this
movie from start to finish that we
actually got to do it I remember the
first day I remember going to the
production office was one thing and
seeing that we actually had a production
office and that you know that there were
clothes pooled in the Wardrobe section
and a production coordinator and
somebody gave me per diem yeah people
working people working like desks that
it looked like they had been sitting at
for a considerable amount of time when
they call to action on the first day
just straight up like roll sound on the
first day I was like oh I thought we're
shooting this on an iPhone with this
trance movie this is actually moving
what's your favorite memory from making
code aid and is there anything you
change oh man anything I would change I
don't think so I mean if you want to get
nitpicky I would go into my own
performance and I'd be like oh I want
this oh we're talking about macro
favorite no I loved it it was an awesome
experience it was it was probably my
favorite work experience I've ever had I
also think that that I think that the
the hiccups along the way and the stuff
that we have to deal with prepared us
for other parts of our career right yeah
it was never gonna go perfectly smooth
no no no project would and we wouldn't
have learned from it and and I was in
Waterworld but you know what was the
other part of question my favorite thing
hmm is there anything you change no I
wouldn't say what was the first part of
the question what was your favorite
memory favorite memory I really liked
our fight scene you me
just teaming up and having a full fight
no doubles no doubles working with a
stunt performer yeah who didn't treat us
like no like we were not no doubles yeah
you would be yes you had a back pad yeah
I was sore yeah you got thrown into it a
window yeah and I was wearing a Canadian
tuxedo and it was hot you're still here
those are you sure we were in the garage
it's hot as balls and yeah and don't you
just sweating and yeah those good times
for what's the most embarrassing
ridiculous thing you've ever seen me do
on set that's a dangerous question I
don't think I'm gonna be weird uh tread
hold up and hold up the entire crew
because you're playing clash Royale yeah
I did send me gems clash Royale
supercell I wouldn't call it
embarrassing but our director of
photography we're setting up for this
beautiful sunset moment on top of this
roof that you see in the movie and we
were busy shooting a video for the
IndieGoGo campaign and as we're walking
up the stairs how's your fantasy
football team doing is that a real
question yeah
horrible almost as bad as you like my
team is so bad rest of the league loves
it cuz we normally just crush everybody
yeah normally I'm I'm I'm parentally in
in the playoffs and I pinned my hopes
this year to lay beyond Belle and Odell
Beckham jr. and that didn't happen
Kamara didn't work out for me I haven't
even gone in the fantasy football chat
I'm so depressed
although dark in there I make is it yeah
Knicks in the playoffs question 5 which
character has the better superpowers
Garrett's TK ability or Connors
electricity I'm gonna go with Garrett's
TK ability because I can use my
superpowers without anyone realizing
that I'm using my superpowers I'd rather
have your abilities in real life
electricity it works for the movie but
like if I was unhappy with the Zoomer
the focus on this carriage
one of these and bring it in and I would
just turn the lights up a little yeah
but what was the most challenging no I'm
sorry it's you I can't was it me no that
was me
we just both answered it I just asked
you number four I asked you number five
okay
exactly this is more challenging banana
what was the most challenging part of
playing Conners electricity scenes a
hundred percent it was during the
sequence where the powers montage in the
factory where I'm lighting all the light
bulbs I'm really just like and we shot
that very early on before you have
really done any scenes where you show
off your power aside from the yeah aside
from the short it was just a lot of
trying to get veins to pop out of my
head and like look like I'm struggling
with like light bulbs on strings you
know as you know you you can't be
self-conscious about it at all you just
have to know that the people in the
visual effects department at play fight
visual effects in Toronto who are
friends of ours are gonna take care of
us yourself aren't just about it how
stupid are you know look the dumbest
really bad you know they used the same
warehouse in Shazam for their powers
montage we shot it first their movie
came out first I'm watching it I was
leading that I'm kidding when he runs up
the halfpipe and tries to fly it's the
warehouse in the background oh I know oh
I'm friends with that I don't actually
see the movies well I I watched
Shazam with with my with my kid and I
FaceTime Zach was offer and he picked up
and the credits rolling and I didn't say
anything to Maddie and she just looks
and she goes I would like to FaceTime me
six yes do you think we should make a
code eight sequel if so which of our
arrowverse friends do you think should
be involved you know first question okay
I do think that we should I do think
that we should make a single I think
that the cool thing about code eight is
that being serious that with Lincoln
City which we haven't gone outside the
boundaries of but I think I feel like
we'd built a world yep that people who
have seen the movie want to know more
about because you and I know from
screenings that we've done all over the
world what's the first question that we
get when do you do anymore right
what happens next are there people in
Lincoln City with other abilities that
we don't know about because we only see
what four five maybe six different types
of I mean there's fire there's brawn
there's a TK there's an electric shavers
kind of shapeshifter a little bit
there's a spoiler
there's a mind reader there's a toilet
yep spoiler there's a mind reader rear
spoiler yes yeah I agree I think that
the movie although being able to live on
its own and close a story is the
beginning and a launching pad for a much
bigger world and is it is constructed as
such is it it's big it feels like the
opening act of something that you want
to keep going with and who are you
inviting Paul Blackthorne
okay that's it you get one yeah Egon
anymore I don't learn Paul Paul's great
who else who's not coming who else let
me pick a second one don't don't don't
read too much into this I'm thinking of
people that I think would be fun to work
with that I haven't necessarily had the
opportunity to as much as I would like
um oh man I would bring Susanna Thompson
who played my mom very cool I feel like
she could be like um like a young leader
yeah and her superpower would just be
she gives you a stern look okay and
you're frozen for the next ten minutes
that's mom power yeah you're not frozen
because you're frozen out of beer yeah
okay okay why should fans go see code
eight when it hits theaters and
on-demand December 13th why should
people go see it
one because we made it with fans twenty
over twenty eight thousand five hundred
forty six people we just looked at it
have donated on the IndieGoGo campaign
and helped make it happen what are the
chances that it happened sorry before
you gets number two what are the chances
that it happens
those 20,000 it happens what is I mean
who knows what it the version of it is
much smaller much more difficult
maybe not nearly as enter definitely not
as entertaining definitely not as
doesn't feel as big would you maybe not
at all but would you have given the same
performance if we didn't have the budget
to pay you all the money that we did
know I'm there for the dollars that's
not true know about paid every dollar is
on screen that's true the other reason
people should go see it is because if
you don't like it and you can tell us
why on Stevens Instagram page he'll send
you a money order for whatever it costs
you to go see it if you send me $23 I
will send you back 12 signed yeah yeah
sure where should people watch it
okay December 13th is it should I pull
it I should get this no I'll get it I'll
get it win let's talk about video on
demand for video no man is gonna be
available on all platforms iTunes that's
easy
everyone's you know that's easy Gore on
iTunes Amazon Vudu every VOD platform
all lots of we think of get all of the
VOD platforms it's also available in
theaters in Los Angeles
Brooklyn Oakland Middletown Delaware
Irving Texas Rochester Hills Michigan
Monroe Washington Spring Hill Florida
Lakeville Minnesota Homestead Florida
Orlando Florida
Thank You Florida and Kansas City
Missouri but we will post all that on
our so yes and you should go see it
because it's really great it's a heidi's
and super proud of it
me too you did well thanks Steve thank
you rob bump-bump Anna and Dan take care
you tuned it all there's no singing the
sing it my agent asked if I want to go
on an audition and it was a musical and
I was like you're out of your mind out
of your mind
I can lip-sync with the best of them
though that's all you have to do in a
movie ask grant and for the musical
episode of their friend
I'm kidding all right let me get out of
here before I cause any more problems
thanks
[Music]